الى الولايات المتحده حيث يبدو ان
المنافسه داخل الحزب الجمهوري لنيل الثقه
للترشح في انتخابات 20 24 على اشدها فبعد
حرب التصريحات بين ترامب وروندي سنتيز
حاكم فلوريدا الان دخل على الخط مايك بنس
نائب دونالد ترامب في فتره رئاسته طبعا
السابقه بالطبع هجوم مبنى الكونجرس عام
2021 هو الباب الامثل يدخل منه في صراعه
مع ترامب فمع فتح وزاره العدل الالباب
امام مقادات ترامب في مسؤوليته عن هجوم
الكابيتال لم يفوت بنس الفرصه حيث شن على
ترامب هجوما لاذعا اعتبر هو الاشد بنس كان
شاهدا على الاحداث عندما اقتحم الالاف من
انصار ترامب المبنى في محاوله لمنع
الكونغرس من التصديق على النتائج
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لعام 2020 والتي
خسرها ترامب امام جو بايدن لما يصدر عن
تعليق يذكر بشان الحادثه في الاشهر
التاليه كما رفض التعاون لجنه مجلس النواب
المعنيه بالتحقيق في الهجوم لكنه كثف
مؤخرا من انتقاداته لموسيري الشغب وترامب
في تغير قد يفهم على انه خطوه نحو ازاحه
ترامب من الترشح في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
القادمه
انتقادات على استحياء ترامب ولكن هذه
المره اتهمه مباشره بتعريض عائلته للخطر
قال ان التاريخ سيحاسبه على دوره في
الهجوم لم يتوقف الامر عن ذلك لكنه وصف ما
حدث في ذلك اليوم بانه وصمت عار تشير
تعليقات بنس الى انه مستعد للنائيه بنفسه
اكثر عن ترامب مع احتدام الحمله
الانتخابيه الرئاسيه التي تجري في 20 24
حتى وان كان هذا يعني خساره دعم ملايين
الناخبين الجمهوريين الذين لا يزالون
يؤيدون ترامب